[Music]
now
[Music]
i have a tick tock that is so absurdly
funny
and i don't know why we haven't done
this on the podcast it's blown my mind
this is comedic gold when i say
this bit is better than any stand-up
special you've seen in the last 300
years i'm not exaggerating do you think
they're doing stand-up specials 300
years ago
do you think there's like a version of
stand-up specials 300 years ago
all right all right let's go
thanks bro
good fight
ladies and gentlemen going to the
scorecards the judges have determined by
unanimous decision
your winner is the red corner
[Laughter]
thanks bro good fight good fight man
what is that on is that vr yeah it's
like some oculus 2 game oh my god this
guy's hung
going in on that guys
i've played the creed boxing game in vr
and
it pissed me off that i never thought to
punch the dude in the dick yeah how have
i never thought to do that jesus shoot a
two to his nose wow
i just like how he really ups the
uppercut combo on the ref
you know it's like those boxes
after he's like we're going to the
scorecard
turn it up right now
yeah i think if you did a comedy special
300 years ago it'd be like if you said
one joke that fell flat they'd like
release a lion and you get killed what
what was 300 years ago like 1800
yeah so oh i don't know
not a [ __ ] scientist dude
1721 what does the world look like a
historian what does 1721 look like i'mma
look up 1721 fit yeah i guess i'm
thinking of like ancient greek yeah
times they probably did have stand-up
specials that's what i'm saying yeah
then it would have been that okay so in
1721 what did 1721 look like oh so
they're all right so they're dressed
like larpers yeah everyone's in bath
robes i should just use tick tock 1721
wardrobe and it'll be some minute long
videos like in the 1700s
we should put that to the test right now
tick tock search engine find that link
survey says
yep wow yep
wow
yeah oh my god
yep
it's pretty mind-blowing dude that's
insane google should be sweating right
now we just google image search that we
got nothing yeah i mean we got like a
bunch of old paintings and [ __ ] this is
but what's more what's more interesting
dude is like
that whole concept of now getting
results and the results are media
instead of text
that is so crazy yep like i was i was
working out the other day
and
i
uh i typed in like a certain type of
curl i didn't even have to watch the
video i just like scrolled down on
youtube and i went down to the one and i
just watched it while listening to my
music like oh it played the gif you just
yeah i just played it like in the search
i'm like okay got it yep
and that's what this [ __ ] is so true and
it's it's this and it's reddit
yeah if you want text based info yeah
it's reddit because you want to know
what real people are doing yeah if you
want to know anything else it's tick
tock yeah
all right so everyone dressed like a
giant like bow wrapping also okay like a
lot of layers yeah
oh because this is probably when they
had to like
if you get if you got bitten by like a
mosquito you were gonna die yeah
okay so
1700 stand up
probably extremely insensitive oh look
there's even a guy doing a bit about the
1800s i was invented in that time period
look at the color of my skin
they would call me the black plague
[ __ ] i'm bodying
i would cross over so many people in the
1800s
that they wouldn't have abolished
slavery
all right let's get out of here
that's pretty good yeah nice that good
open mic vibe it really is
that open mic vibration by the way
raleigh north carolina next week i'll be
there
date state 16th to the 18th i was trying
to feel something yeah yeah it's kind of
like it's kind of like listening to clb
and donda that was the other thing i
wanted to say i love how
after
a decade of music basically people are
finally like
drake doesn't really hit the same who
gives a [ __ ] actually you're still gonna
have to listen to music yeah not a fan
yeah music sucks yeah it sucks i drive
in silence i prefer to argue when i
drive that's why dads don't like driving
to music
they don't like driving they only like
driving to music when it's with their
kids yeah and drown them out yeah
they're tired of hearing your ass talk
that's that's why your dads are so
excited like driving you somewhere
because your ass is out the house they
can't wait like [ __ ] yeah
i'm 50 now and an hour feels like 10
minutes so for this next 10 minutes i'm
gonna not hear anyone [ __ ] talking
in my house they go in the house and
their wife's like
[Music]
the silent purr of the tesla yo speaking
of let's kid cuddy this whole [ __ ]
i was going on this website that was all
about like tesla car deaths what yeah
okay it's tesladeaths.com
so this is like some what in the [ __ ]
oh this was our original search we we
got distracted this is not the dude i
remember jack 3d
damn who's that
jack 3ds nuts in your mind damn jack 3d
was a
that was like a pre-workout
i never took pre-workout i've never
taken it me neither maybe like once yeah
yeah it's a pre-workout damn yeah it was
banned
yeah because they're all like synthetic
they're like one molecule away from
being actual an actual amphetamine i'm
pretty sure well there was one i don't
know which supplement it was that bsn
was putting out i thought and it was
just like basically steroids yeah
like a bunch of high schoolers that's
the thing
now
they just get trend now they just get
the actual stereo yeah
no need to hide it also so cool how
supplements aren't regulated
are they not no because it's like it's
like fda doesn't regulate supplements
really yeah that's why it's such a
booming industry
because you can just make something yeah
you can just get in and just start
but then you can get like shut down
eventually right yeah like there has to
be some sort of governing body on that
um
if there is it's not very effective
it's not not regulated at all
like if we could basically take a bunch
of like chili flakes and de-flavor them
crush them up and color them pink bam we
got g fuel
g fuel yeah that would be our we could
like just sell
i'm just saying that do to you though we
have to have like a something that does
something to you this makes you a little
hot yeah yeah
that's it i think it's worth little
speeds of sweat on your nose yeah i take
g fuel too and it seems to work
tmg fuel um
yeah
you